منذ ان اندلعت هذه الاحتياجات هنا في
ايران واسلوب القمع واحد اصوات الرصاص
تعلو مع كل تجمهر للمحتجين من الشباب
والشابات
صحيح انه اسلوب واحد لاستهداف متظاهرين
لكن للنظام طرقا مختلفه لتنفيذه تختلف بين
الرجال والنساء
فالجروح التي تتعرض لها النساء المتظاهرات
تختلف كليا عن مناطق اصابه الرجال شهادات
كانت صادمه كشف عنها الاطباء والمسعفون
الايرانيون لصحيفه الجاردن البريطانيه
قوات الامن الايرانيه تنتقي اماكن الاصابه
بعنايه شديده ومن مسافه قريبه من خلال
بنادق الصيد والرصاص المطاطي الذي تستعمله
بهدف قمع الاحتجاجات حيث تعمدت استهداف
الاعضاء التناسليه للنساء المتظاهرات في
الاحتجاجات بعكس الرجال الذين غالبا ما
تكون اصاباتهم على مستوى الارجل او
الارداف او الظاهر
كما ان الصور التي حصلت عليها صحيفه من
الاطباء الذين عالجوا ضحايا المظاهرات
تظهر تعرض المحتجين لجروح خطيره في جميع
انحاء اجسادهم خاصه على مستوى العيون
والاعضاء التناسليه بالنسبه للنساء
اختصاصيون طبيون حذروا من خطوره هذه
الاصابات والتي يمكن ان تترك مئات شباب
الايرانيين باعاقات دائمه وفي الوقت الذي
سيحتاج فيه المتظاهرون المصابين الى علاج
ومتابعه طبيبيه تفرض السلطات مراقبه شديده
على المستشفيات
لتعقب المحتجين سلطان العبان العربيه